voters cast their ballots in kyrgyzstan
for the third time in
six months the referendum was called by
the new president
sadhar japarov who asked the country to
approve
changes to the constitution but critics
say
they could pave the way for
authoritarianism and misrule
i don't think only one man should decide
everything there is a proverb that says
you only find truth through debate
the more opinions you have the better it
is for the country's development
japan was freed from jail by supporters
in october during protests after
parliamentary elections were annulled
following widespread allegations of vote
buying
by pro-government parties
the government collapsed in what kyrgyz
called their third revolution in three
decades since independence
japan says the last 10 years of the
parliamentary system
under the current constitution has been
a failure
and kyrgyzstan is not ready for a
parliamentary democracy
the people have been really feeling that
the parliament has been the seat of
irresponsibility
that there's no uh there's nobody with
who
at whom the bucket stops as it were and
the
president has really picked up on that
sense
sentiment among the people that we have
a constitution that doesn't
assign clear responsibility to anyone
and i'm the one who is going to take
full responsibility myself
i will answer for everything that
happens in this country and just give me
the power
supporters of the proposed
constitutional changes say freedom of
speech and democratic rights will be
protected
but order needs to be restored to
government after years of mismanagement
and corruption
we've had 33 prime ministers in 30 years
can you imagine that
and always the appointments and
decisions were made by the president
behind the scenes
which was unconstitutional the prime
minister was the victim of those
decisions
the constitutional changes mean the
president will be able to act
transparently
kyrgyzstan is often described as the
most democratic country
in central asia and president japaroff
says
that altering the country's constitution
will not
change that but there are many people
here who are afraid
that he represents a problem on the path
towards full democracy a path
that they have struggled to build since
independence
30 years ago john stratford al jazeera
bishop